one of the key reasons anyone buys a
console is for the exclusives titles
that only appear on that platform but
knowing the difference between a full
timed and console exclusive can
sometimes be a little confusing So today
we're going through all 26 PlayStation
exclusive games coming in 2024 and
Beyond be sure to leave your top three
in the comments below and maybe leave a
like to save my dying Channel let's do
this rise of the Ronin arrives on March
22nd a PlayStation 5 exclusive single
player action RPG set in 19th century
Japan when carrying a katana was a
normal thing to do we play as a
mysterious Ronin whose actions will
dynamically change this open world
meaning the story will play out
differently for different players due to
the decisions they make an ally for one
player will become an enemy for another
rise of the Ronin began development in
2015 and contains the team that brought
us Neo and Ninja gider gameplay will
take inspiration from both those games
with well-timed attacks reposts and
paries yet it'll be less intense than
Neo as not every gamer enjoys punishing
Souls like combat and one last note
we've seen our nameless character on
Horseback and also utilizing flying
machines to get around this huge open
world I for one can't wait rise of the
Ronin is a PS5 exclusive coming on March
22nd did you know 2024 is a leap here
and on that extra day comes the next
Final Fantasy 7 remake episode rebirth
the retelling of the PS1 classic shocked
Gamers by changing the story The Rebel
Avalanche team have now escaped midgar
and Venture into an open world so big
it's on two PS5
discs the gameplay retains what we saw
in the remake with real-time Hack and
Slash and quick swapping between your
teammates a cool addition are the
Synergy moves when multiple members of
the squad build up their gauges enough
an extra epic attack can be triggered a
real badass moment rebirth will be
filled with side quest activities like
Monster hunting the typical RPG elements
like finding resources and crafting
potions and of course this crazy
compelling set of characters Final
Fantasy 7 rebirth is another PlayStation
exclusive dropping on February
29th here's Stella Blade the ultra
stylish third person combat focused
action game is set in the near future
when humanity is driven away from Earth
after losing a war to pesky aliens to
reclaim our home Eve and her Squad must
perfect their abilities to beat the heck
out of anything that stands in their way
visually Stella blade looks amazing with
both blade and pistol in hand we've
already seen more boss fights in two
trailers than we see in entire video
games and some really impressive speed
sections too new moves will be unlocked
during the campaign as your version of
Eve continues to evolve based on the
skills she uses the most Stella blade
may not have a final release date yet
but we do know it's a PS5 exclusive have
you seen Pacific Drive what a weird game
basically we have a car I'm told this is
a station wagon and we leave the garage
to collect resources and upgrade
materials then come back to apply them
to the vehicle and go out again that may
seem like the most boring video game
ever made yet all four people I spoke to
who played this say it's so unique it's
a must play Pacific drive has us rolling
through Supernatural phenomenons making
each venture out onto the roads a brand
new EXP experience unpredictable things
occur constantly the rarer the
experience the better the loot if you
can get back to the garage and keep your
car roadworthy Pacific Drive is a
firstperson racing radik and it's here
on February 22nd this one is a console
exclusive which means if you prefer to
buy it on PC you're free to do
[Music]
so after the amazing Alan Wake 2
released lashia many gamers want another
mystery horror game and it just so
happens that Silent Hill 2 the remake is
here in 2024 set in third person we play
as James who receives a letter from his
deceased wife from the town of Silent
Hill he then goes there and soon
realizes this place is cursed interviews
have suggested the style will be similar
to the recent re remakes yet I reckon
it's more like Alan Wake as our hero is
not the most versed at fighting expect
reality altering psychological horror
it'll be lovely to be chased by Pyramid
Head once again there's no fixed release
date right now i' take a guess that we
should expect Silent Hill to to around
Halloween time on both PS5 and PC this
one is a Ed exclusive which means our
Xbox brothers and sisters will get this
game they just have to wait a little
longer than everybody else a game
arriving in 2024 which we know very
little about is Concord right now it's
just a CG trailer in space what we do
know is that this is a new PVP
multiplayer firstperson shooter from
firewalk Studios launching on PS5 and PC
in 2024 making Concord and another
console exclusive no gameplay yet so
let's move on much sooner than that
comes Grand blue fantasy relink the
single and multiplayer RPG takes us back
to the original game with many
characters returning yet a brand new
story is told here when playing alone AI
will fill the slots in your team but
it's best played with other real players
story-wise the Big Bad Gal is trying to
come back to this realm and needs to
restore the Forbidden Primal so it's our
job to take down all the Primal beasts
to prevent that grand blue fantasy link
is a console exclusive coming to PS4 PS5
and PC on February 1st February also
brings hell divers 2 another console
exclusive online we team up with other
hell divers to go Planet Side in a super
hostile alien world designed for
cooperative play so the loadouts we
choose need to complement each other to
survive the horde missions completed
lead to upgraded weapons and armor and
your ship too hell divers comes to PC
and PlayStation 5 on February
8th
here's something a little different foam
Stars a four on four party shooter which
effectively is an attempt to build a
Splatoon community on Playstation
instead of spreading paint though we
instead use bubbles we can then surf on
those bubbles to fill the arena with
even more Mountains of the stuff combat
is fully supported as the foam is
weaponized in the most familyfriendly
way we then use slide kicks to defeat
enemies and save our foamed up teammates
I've been trying to delay this video as
fo star's information is due very soon
in fact on January 16th then we should
know if the game is free to play part of
a subscription or a full-priced outing
as I'm writing this foam stars is an
exclusive PlayStation game although I'm
hoping other platforms get this so a
real Community can be built around it
we'll find out more details on January
16th a game most of the community is
eagerly awaiting is Wolverine from the
same team that brought us the sublime
recent Spider-Man games set in third
person Wolverine would have the ability
to wall climb thanks to those Claws and
other abilities like his incredible
healing powers or his insane sense of
smell sadly information was stolen from
the developers Insomniac which suggests
the game will be released in 2026 and
not sooner which we all thought also
stolen were many playable sections of
the game and as those leaks were
actually theft I won't be showing them
here just know that Wolverine is in very
good hands gam play is expected to be
more brutal in nature like God of War
rather than the reasonably
child-friendly Spider-Man and Ratchet
and Clank games and get this officially
the world of Wolverine will be the very
same one that Miles Peter and co inhabit
on the PlayStation the potential for
crossovers is immeasurable will we see
any official gameplay this year I don't
think so but I'd love to be
wrong sometime in 2024 we will see
Phantom Blade zero we play as Soul an
elite assassin framed for a crime he
didn't commit now hunted by a mysterious
order we have 66 days to find out the
truth fighting back against human and
monster alike with your trusty blade
supporting both Stealth gameplay and
allout attack we are promised
environmental combat too as the game is
built around Chinese kung fu and this
carries over to the blades we use too
each cor sword has a different length
and a different weight making our hero
fight differently the more I look into
Phantom Blade zero the more impressed I
become coming to PS5 and PC so this one
is a console exclusive with a playable
demo coming soon something a little
different is towers of a gasar I'm sure
I said that wrong an open world fantasy
exploration game in which the assignment
is to rebuild civilization and venturing
out to find new plants and building
materials as this is based in fantasy
the unexpected flora and FAA we
encounter will make for some truly
unexpected moments from dinosaurs
roaming freely to whatever these things
are in one section we see a new plant
introduced and over time it grows into
this Beast of Nature and allows us to
climb up to new areas which we couldn't
reach before towers of agasa is a
console exclusive on PlayStation 5 and
PC and then we have baby steps the
weirdest game of 2024 a coordination
game in which putting one foot in front
of the other is a challenge if you've
played quop or octo dad you get the
premise here it's the most basic
gameplay of all but it will be one of
the most infuriating games of the year
too climbing walls mud Trails tight
ropes Mountain Toops and grappling too
and one slip and you may return to the
beginning baby steps comes to
PlayStation 5 and PC hopefully in
2024 fans of games like journey and abzu
you should keep an eye on sword of the
sea another console exclusive and
another free flowing zenite game from
giant squid we surf on a giant
hoverboard over sand dunes and explore
this stylized World unlocking its
secrets and finding meaning in this
abandoned realm releasing on PlayStation
5 and PC death stranding 2 AKA DS2 is
reportedly nearing the end of
development the sequel to The much loved
and muched death stranding saw a
post-apocalyptic USA engulfed by this
black goo which linked the worlds of the
living and the dead in this constant
limbo we then carried packages around
trying not to fall over while carrying a
baby in a bottle what's not to
understand there DS2 looks to include a
time Jump with Baby Lou a little bigger
Sam now grayhead and fragile body is no
longer scarred death stranding director
hiio kajima stated additional dialogue
recording and voiceovers are scheduled
and work on another unrelated game has
already begun which hopefully means a
release date is imminent as the first
game initially released as a PlayStation
exclusive and as it's built on a
PlayStation engine we are expecting the
same again have you seen lost soul aside
it's yet another hacken SL RPG built
around incredible speed and finesse seen
by many as the natural progression of
Devil May cry's combat our hero is kaser
and he's accompanied by a mythical
dragon creature who can morph into the
weapons we need to conquer this world as
you'd expect from a hack and slash game
combos are a huge part of the appeal and
now the game has massive fin Financial
backing the boss fights keep getting
bigger and bigger lost soul aside is
coming to PlayStation 5 and
PC another Chinese game in development
is Project the perceiver out of all the
games we've looked at today this one is
the most Souls like of them all with
perfect pares and crucially timed
attacks pivotal to progression set in a
fully open world during all out War you
must stand up for our ideals and fight
as the land falls into chaos that's
pretty much all we know we should find
out more this year you'd be surprised
how many games are in development for
PS5 in China like Dara land of water
scar another RPG inspired by dark souls
and more recently Neo Exile edged Exile
edged not sure how to pronounce that one
is a frantic action game combining third
person shooting with hacken SL melee we
have shower American story coming to PC
and PlayStation and EAS take on the
USA's B movie tropes and we literally
play as a movie stunt woman who is
brought back to life to save the world
China is working a lot on these hack and
slash games right now and one more conv
Valaria a third person team shooter info
on these Chinese games are quite limited
so let's put a pin in them for now but
no there's a lot of them oh here's a
game which stands out from the crowd
what do you get if Zelda breath of the
wild devs team up with genin impact devs
you get infinity Nikki an open world
dress up game Nikki explores the land to
find new garments and when a full set is
found she unlocks a new ability kind of
like if you dress as a mermaid you can
swim underwater or you find a Space
Ranger outfit and you can Venture into
space I love this idea and suddenly
their Twitter account is active again
and suggests this is the year Nikki
arrives for players who like Heist games
you should keep an eye on Fair games
right now we only have a CGI trailer but
in interviews the studio outlines a PVP
sandbox that requires Mastery and
creativity every time you play we'll
find out more about this one coming to
PS5 and PC later in the year I'm going
to butcher this next game name Evo
tinction it's a stealth hacking game as
we try and remain as hidden as possible
in this sci-fi setting we are a oneman
infiltration Mission into an AI
controlled secure location the premise
is outthinking the machines to disable
their security and do you remember
little devil inside the Indie action
adventure title with Rog likee elements
set in a Victorian Steam Punk style we'd
play as a university Professor who
specializes in Paranormal Activity and
goes on daring combat field excursions
it looked great and had an amazing sense
of humor
too but it vanished well 2024 be the
year it finally returns of course here
back in January there is The Last of Us
Part Two remastered just about to
release which brings the Survival action
game into the current gen space adding
new content like a brutal Rog likee
survival mode and cut levels from the
original game with developers commentary
over the top and if you already own The
Last of Us Part Two on PS4 it's just a
$10 upgrade to get the PS5 version good
value we did it 26 games covered thanks
for staying till the end I'm Adam you're
awesome my voice hurts see you